der kopfhörer ist eines der begehrtesten
technik gadgets überhaupt durch den
siegeszug der smartphones ist er das
trendprodukt der letzten jahre
insbesondere drahtlose tonübertragung
per bluetooth und noise cancelling also
die auslöschung von störendem schalk
sind der heiße scheiß ich habe mal fünf
der begehrten exemplare genauer unter
die lupe genommen und ich erklären wie
das ganze genau funktioniert und am ende
erfährt er welche kopfhörer die nase
vorn hat war ein klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ich stelle euch vor den eleganten libra
turnier den für seine beste berühmten
beats studio 3 wireless den beau sind
gut 35 vom erfinder des noise cancelling
es den sennheiser pcx 550 von einem der
audio unternehmen in deutschland und den
sony bh 1000x m2 aber erstmal gibt es
etwas know how auf die ohren
stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm also audio
also ton das ist ja nichts anderes als
schallwellen also so kann man sie
dargestellt
aber genau genommen sind es gar keine
wellen sondern es ist die durch
wellenmuster darstellbare komprimierung
und die komprimierung von luft das
bringt dann unser trommelfell genau in
diesen rhythmus wie der schall darauf
trifft zum schwingen so kann man eine
schallwelle darstellen genau wie die
musik die wir hören wollen treffen auch
störgeräusche als solche schallwellen
auf unser ohr
die schallwellen der störgeräusche
sollen jetzt aber zerstört werden aber
wie dazu gehen wir mal in die
vergangenheit der tonübertragung denn da
gab es schon mal so etwas das ist ein
symmetrisches ton kabel es überträgt den
ton auf zwei leitungen und da machte es
etwas um störgeräusche zu unterdrücken
zum beispiel die von stromkabeln die
brummen nämlich mit 50 hertz lustig vor
sich hin und stören so ein parallel
laufendes ton kabel 50 hertz ist die
frequenz mit der plus und minuspol beim
wechsel stromkabel wechseln 50 mal pro
sekunde ist hier und mal hier plus oder
minus was passiert jetzt also wann
symmetrischen kabel das ist einfach und
ziemlich genial
auf der einen seite wird das signal
normal übertragen und auf der anderen
seite genau andersrum also worum die
schallwelle wird quasi gespiegelt würde
man jetzt am ende die beiden kabel
einfach zusammen schalten wird etwas
total irre es passieren die schallwellen
würden sich gegenseitig auslöschen also
das hier passiert sie ergeben 0
man würde einfach nichts mehr hören
stille
nur die störgeräusche würde man noch
hören wie zb das brummen eines daneben
liegenden stromkabels aber jetzt wird
etwas noch mal genial jahres gemacht
die gespiegelten schall werden werden
widergespiegelt und löschen sich also
nicht mehr aus also das wird klasse
wieder hoch gelegt also das ganze sieht
jetzt so aus hier ist das ein signal und
das andere wird jetzt einfach dazu
gelegt mit den störgeräuschen passiert
jetzt aber folgendes sie die vorher
diese beiden wellen überlagert haben
die sind ja auf beiden wellen gleich
also hier ist genau das gleiche
störgeräusche wie auf dieser welle und
jetzt könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen
was passiert wenn man das ganze umdreht
was passiert mit den störgeräuschen die
auf den beiden wellen sind da passiert
nämlich jetzt folgendes die werden ja
jetzt andersherum zusammengelegt nämlich
so und die löschen sich jetzt
gegenseitig aus einfach aber genial
störgeräusche sind absolut nicht mehr zu
hören und so können auf konzerten im
tonstudio und sonst wo die kabel
komplett durcheinander liegen neben
stromkabeln starkstromkabel und anderen
störquellen und nichts ist dann davon zu
hören eine absolut simple und geniale
erfindung aber eigentlich müsste das ja
auch mit dem schall selbst funktionieren
also nicht nur elektronisch sondern auch
akustisch die firma bose testete 1986
den ersten kopfhörer mit active noise
cancelling drei jahre später konnten sie
dann gekauft werde zunächst waren sie
nur für flugzeugpiloten gedacht weil
neues cancelling hier deutlich
praktischen nutzen brachte und die
piloten so viel besser per funk und auch
untereinander sprechen konnten
das prinzip ist ähnlich wie beim kabel
nur unendlich viel komplizierter hier
muss der ton erst mal außerhalb des
kopfhörers mit einem oder mehreren
mikrofonen aufgefangen werden aus diesen
hall wellen muss dann ein signal
errechnet werden dass die dämmung des
kopfhörers und den weg zum trommelfell
genau berücksichtigt da jedes ohr anders
ist und auch jeder kopfhörer kommt es
hierbei dem algorithmus extrem auf das
know how des herstellers haben nicht
umsonst gilt als einer der besten
hersteller für noise cancelling
kopfhörer dieses signal wird dann wieder
gespiegelt zusätzlich der musik signal
hinzugefügt und löscht die störgeräusche
aus wie gut dass die verschiedenen
hersteller können das werden wir jetzt
sehen beziehungsweise hören
dann heben wir uns mal den kopfhörer das
noise cancelling erfinders bose für den
schluss auf aber erst mal die übersicht
wir haben uns angesehen den beats studio
3 weil es für etwa 320 240 euro den sony
wh 1000x m2 für rund 300 euro
den lepra turnier den gibt es schon 470
euro dann den sennheiser pcx 550 4 250
bis 280 euro und den bose pc 35 430 oder
fangen wir mal mit dem preiswerten debra
tokyo electron er an
er unterscheidet sich von allen anderen
durch sign on ihr design aus der
tragekomfort kann hier je nach etwas
eingeschränkt sein da der kopfhörer
etwas auf die ohren drückt da er keine
ohrpolster art die den druck von den
rohren abhalten und er hat noch einen
nachteil die bedienung muss man sich
merken kreisförmige bewegungen lauter
und leiser play und pause jeweils ein
mal tippen genau so nimmt man einen
telefonanruf an oder beendeten und mit
zwei mal tippen kommt man zum nächsten
titel noise cancelling und das finde ich
sehr praktisch kann in vier stufen mit
dieser taste ausgewählt werden je
nachdem wie viel man noch von außen
hören möchte das noise cancelling
funktioniert dabei tadellos wobei es als
offener kopfhörer nicht ganz so effektiv
ist wie bei einem geschlossenen
kopfhörer die akkulaufzeit beim libra
ton ist ganz ordentlich 22 stunden da
gehe ich mal drei punkte
der sound bei einem libretto ncua depp
ist ordentlich eigentlich aber er kann
nicht ganz mit den geschlossenen
kopfhörer mithalten deshalb für den
sound beim libra tokio hat nur zwei
punkte
jakober zum sennheiser ein wirklich sehr
sehr guter kopfhörer tragekomfort 1a
passt perfekt zumindest offen meine
ohren der sound ist absolut spitze beim
sennheiser da geben sich drei kopfhörer
eigentlich nichts in diesem test er ist
einer von den drei spitzenreitern
allerdings beim noise cancelling liegt
er nur im mittelfeld ich gebe ihm drei
punkte wobei man sagen muss die liegen
alle alle sehr dicht beieinander
bei der akkulaufzeit gehört der
sennheiser zu den absoluten
spitzenreitern also fast ist er der
beste 30 stunden das ist schon eine
menge vier punkte ja das ist der witz
wenn man den auspackt dann erfährt man
dir zu bedienen ist dass er mir
aufkleber drauf allerdings wenn man dann
hat dann muss man sich merken wir zu
bedienen ist ja knallrot legende die
beats der tragekomfort auch hier
spitzenklasse und beim sound da gehört
er nicht zur spitzenklasse
das sind andere kopfhörer er ist so ein
bisschen mulmig verschwommen nicht so
klar wie unsere spitzenreiter deshalb
drei punkte für den sound von beats
studio 3 wireless beim noise cancelling
da ist er eher hinten dran das muss man
sagen er ist sogar schlechter als der
offene liberation cueva und ist wirklich
am hinteren ende
allerdings war muss sagen es ist
subjektives hängt auch von den eigenen
ohren ab aber ich persönlich würde wenn
es um die störgeräusche und darum geht
einen anderen kopfhörer wählen
akkulaufzeit dagegen im mittelfeld drei
punkte 22 stunden das ist ganz okay
kommen wir zum sony ein absolut schickes
stück muss man sagen und er gehört auch
zu den absoluten spitzenreitern im klang
und er
und er redet mit einem nein absolut
klarer sound für mich subjektiv alle
frequenzen ordentlich vertreten
sauber und ich bin absolut super dazu
kommt auch noch tragekomfort auch
absolut perfekt zumindest für meine
ohren und das noise cancelling ist hier
absolute spitzenklasse
das liegt auch mit sicherheit daran dass
man ihn auf seine ohren kalibrieren kann
das heißt er misst die unterschiede die
es bei den verschiedenen ohren gibt und
kann so beurteilen wie der schall sich
im gehörgang bewegt um daraufhin die
unterdrückung der störgeräusche
abzustimmen aber andersrum ist er der
schlechteste kopfhörer wenn wir ihn mit
allen anderen vergleichen selbst
verglichen mit dem libretto ncua der ja
offen ist dieser kopfhörer lässt am
meisten der musik die man hört nach
außen das ist natürlich ein nachteil
deswegen nur einen punkt wer also in der
u-bahn s-bahn im zug im flugzeug
niemanden stören will ist mit diesem
kopfhörer nicht optimal bedient kommt
natürlich auf die musik an die man hört
aber es könnte schwierig werden
und nochmal absolute höchstpunktzahl für
den sony fünf punkte für die
akkulaufzeit 32 stunden das ist die
beste akkulaufzeit des testfeldes also
mit dem kann man schon ein paar tage zu
bringen der bose absolute legende vom
erfinder des noise cancelling es
deswegen hier unser letzter test
kandidat tragekomfort wie bei allen
geschlossenen kopfhörer absolut optimal
da drückt nichts und auch nach stunden
wird man den kopfhörer nicht auf den
ohren der sound auch absolute
spitzenklasse klar kompletter
frequenzbereich starke bässe mitten
höhen alles ist da ich finde man kann
mit dem alle arten von musik ganz toll
hören ich habe von orgelmusik
funktioniert der zu den schwierigsten
kandidaten gehört das ist alles glasklar
aber akkulaufzeit der bose ist das
absolute schlusslicht mit 17 stunden ich
kann nur sagen
geht man eure entwicklungsabteilung
macht da was dran deshalb nur zwei
punkte für den busen bei der
akkulaufzeit ja noise cancelling und das
ist wirklich ein bisschen frappierend da
ist er nicht der absolute top
spitzenkandidat wie gesagt die gegen
alle sehr dicht beieinander
aber ich würde sagen der böse ist nicht
ganz so gut wie der sony der hier
wirklich absolute spitzenklasse ist und
alles weg hält der bose außengeräusche
ja nicht das absolute highlight aber
auch nicht am ende des testfeldes drei
punkten gutes mittelfeld mann sollte es
mal ausprobieren vielleicht mal mit
freunden in den elektronikmarkt gehen
und da auch selbst vergleichen wer bei
der eigenen musik es kommt auch darauf
an was man an musik hört bei techno kann
es durchaus bei dem ein oder anderen
kopfhörer schwierig werden wie gesagt
der pause im mittelfeld
wir testen die kopfhörer mit zwei
geräuschen die wir hier hinten auf der
stereoanlage abspielen und gucken wie
stark sie den ton abhalten von den ohren
also diese äußeren störgeräusche
geräusch eines der worte bahnhof in
london
ja ganz gutes neues cancelling ist
kommen noch ein paar geräusche hier bei
der bahnstation durch hochfrequente vor
allen dingen
auch sehr gutes neues also hier würde
ich sagen auch die tiefen und geräusche
alle weg noch ein paar hohe stimmen
der ist gegenüber dem sennheiser und dem
beats auch im hochfrequenten bereich
deutlich wirkungsvoller also man hat das
gefühl dass neues cancelling geht über
mehr frequenzen verrückt obwohl der
libration offen ist ungefähr ähnliche
noise cancelling wirkung wie beim pose
ich würde sagen noise cancelling ist
beim sony tatsächlich am besten wirklich
dicht und über den gesamten
frequenzbereich hierbei der waterloo
station geräusch 2 ein einfaches
maschinen geräusch von der stehenden
u-bahn
ähnlich wie bei der waterloo station
beim beats hohe töne kommen noch durch
tiefe werden herausgefiltert
auch bei diesen dauerhaften
maschinengeräusche mein subjektiver
eindruck beim sennheiser etwas besser
als der beats auch der bose bei dem
maschinengeräusche hohe frequenzen
kommen noch leicht durch während der
lieber dom bei der bahn station noch mit
dem bose fast gleichauf lag hier bei
einem kontinuierlichen geräusch ist er
etwas schwächer
und beim sony würde ich sagen bei diesem
kontinuierlichen geräusche kommen die
mittleren frequenzen etwas besser durch
insgesamt muss man sagen bei allen
kopfhörern die unterschiede sind beim
noise cancelling minimal es hängt glaube
ich auch extrem von den eigenen ohren um
vom gehörgang ab wie stark das noise
cancelling bei einem selbst wirkt man
sollte sich also mal anhören unter
realen bedingungen in den
elektronikmärkten ist ja meistens auch
ein ganz gutes hintergrundgeräusch da
kann man das ganz gut testen die
unterschiede sind auf jeden fall minimal
aber sie sind signifikant und man sollte
sich das glaube ich wirklich selbst
anleihen und wir haben uns noch ein ganz
besonderer test ausgedacht die geräusche
die nach außen bringen also die musik
die nach außen dringt der kopfhörer
die haben wir in der berliner u-bahn
getestet
ja der liebert rompuy der schalt schon
ein bisschen aus man hört ein bisschen
aber der preis ist unschlagbar
ja da ist der witz wirklich unschlagbar
kaum etwas dringt nach draußen von der
musik die man so hört also der ideale
begleiter in der öffentlichkeit
ja wer hätte das gedacht beim sony
dringen die meisten geräusche nach
draußen also die in anderen passagiere
hören am meisten von der musik die man
hört techno ist da vielleicht nicht so
geeignet super klang aber da ist er
wirklich nicht der beste sondern ist am
ende unserer testreihen
tatsächlich ist der böse einigermaßen
dicht aber mittelfeld muss man sagen
man bekommt schon etwas bei lauter musik
mehr mit als bei anderen kopfhörern
muss man wissen wenn man diesen
kopfhörer kauft
der sennheiser da muss man sagen das ist
unsere nummer 2 was die schall
tätigkeiten angeht und bekommt kaum
etwas mit von dem was man hört was
vielleicht auch an den weichen polstern
liegt die auch sehr angenehm sind also
top in dieser kategorie
ja das ist unser testergebnis erst mal
ich glaube einer der entscheidenden
gründe um kopfhörer zu kaufen ist
natürlich der sound da sind hier bose
sennheiser und sony die absoluten
spitzenreiter wichtig natürlich auch
hier noise cancelling auch hier hinten
ist er das spitzenfeld wobei der
libration unser ja preissieger quasi ja
auch ziemlich gut aussieht was ich noch
für ein wichtiges kriterium halte ist
wie viel geräusch wie für musik dringt
nach außen auch da die unterschiede sind
nicht riesig aber sie können dann doch
für den ein oder anderen entscheidend
seien hier der sony ansonsten wirklich
unser bester kopfhörer bei unserem rein
subjektiven test sage ich natürlich ist
da nicht so stark wie ein beats der aber
im klang wieder nicht so toll ist also
es gibt verschiedene kriterien überlegt
selbst guckt euch an testet die links zu
allen kopfhörern die gibt es natürlich
unten in der video beschreibung klick
drauf informiert euch noch näher und ja
wenn er einen lieb gewonnen habt dann
greift zu ja wenn ihr kein video von
klicks und verpassen wollt dann würde
ich mal sagen drückt mir hier ein abo
aufs auge vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr über
neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit den zehn top erfolgsfaktoren
um erfolgreich auf youtube zu werden und
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran